So let's think about what other repeated code can be factored out here.
Even though it's a tiny piece of logic, the code that adds a .loc property to
a new car object is being written twice here.
How do you think we could go about factoring that out?
Well, we can use the same technique we did of writing a function that does work
for us over and over again.
Now, I'm going to give this function the name carlike.
Since it's job is to augment an object with the properties needed to be
considered a car.
Now it's true that in this oversimplified example,
the function we're going to be writing will do almost nothing.
Since car seems to be pretty simple,
they really only have a .loc property on them.
But in a real program, objects have a lot more properties.
So this carlike function should be made to take some car object as an input,
then do some work on it and then return it.
And when we call it on our car objects,
we expect it to add this .loc property for us.
As such, we'll need a pass the location value into carlike so
that it knows what to set the car's location to.
When a function like this one, takes in an object as it's input and
then augments that object with some properties or functionality.
The carlike function here would qualify as a decorator.
It's common to use adjectives as the names for
your decorator functions, hence the name carlike